>>> SIGNIFICANT BREAKING NEWS
JUST INTO US.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS AGREED TO
TAKE UP A MAJOR ABORTION CASE
NEXT TERM CONCERNING A
CONTROVERSIAL MISSISSIPPI LAW
THAT BANS MOST ABORTIONS AFTER
15 WEEKS.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG TEST
FOR THE ROE V. WADE DECISION
WHICH INITIALLY LEGALIZED
ABORTION PARTICULARLY WITH THE
6-3 CONSERVATIVE MAKEUP OF THE
COURT.
JOINING US JESSICA SCHNEIDER
ALONG WITH ELIE HONIG.
JESSICA, FIRST TO YOU.
TELL US EXACTLY WHAT THE SUPREME
COURT ANNOUNCED THIS MORNING AND
HOW SOON WILL WE SEE THIS GO
BEFORE THEM?
>> WELL, THIS WON'T ACTUALLY BE
HEARD BY THE SUPREME COURT UNTIL
NEXT TERM SO SOMETIME AFTER
OCTOBER.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
LAW WAS BLOCKED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT HERE.
IT REMAINS BLOCKED.
IT WILL REMAIN BLOCKED UNTIL THE
SUPREME COURT HEARS IT AND THEN
ISSUES A DECISION.
WE ARE LOOKING AT AT LEAST
ANOTHER YEAR OF THIS LAW
BLOCKED.
THIS IS A MAJOR LAW OUT OF
MISSISSIPPI, IT BLOCKS ABORTIONS
AFTER 15 WEEKS, EXCEPT FOR CASES
OF A MEDICAL EMERGENCY, SEVERE
FETAL ABNORMALITIES, BUT IT DOES
NOT MAKE EXCEPTIONS FOR RAPE OR
INCEST.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
CASE COMES NOW THAT THIS COURT
IS SOLIDLY CONSERVATIVE, 6-3, IT
ALSO COMES NOW WITH JUSTICE AMY
CONEY BARRETT ON THE COURT.
WE KNOW AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN SHE
HAS EXPRESSED HER ANTI-ABORTION
VIEWS, HOWEVER, DURING HER
CONFIRMATION HEARING SHE DID SAY
THAT SHE WOULDN'T LET HER
PRIVATE FEELINGS, HER OPINIONS
IMPACT HER DECISION.
BUT ONE JUSTICE WHO HAS SPOKEN
OUT REPEATEDLY ABOUT ROE v. WADE
SAYING THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
OVERTURNED IS JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS.
HE HAS MADE NO SECRET OF HIS
OPINION THAT IT SHOULD BE
OVERTURNED.
I MEAN, WE HEARD FROM HIM
RECENTLY SAYING THAT ROE v. WADE
HAS CREATED THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION OUT OF WHOLE CLOTH
WITHOUT A SHRED OF SUPPORT FROM
THE CONSTITUTION'S TEXT.
SO THIS WILL BE A REAL TEST FOR
THE COURT.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN THE COURT
WEIGH IN RECENTLY ON SOME
ABORTION-RELATED ISSUES.
IT WAS JUST BACK IN JANUARY WHEN
THE COURT ACTUALLY REIMPOSED
RESTRICTIONS ON THE ABORTION
DRUG THAT WOMEN COULD PREVIOUSLY
GET WITHOUT VISITING A DOCTOR,
THEY REIMPOSED THE RULES STATING
THAT WOMEN HAD TO GO IN-PERSON
IN ORDER TO GET THIS ABORTION
DRUG.
SO WE'VE SEEN ALREADY THE COURT
SORT OF MOVING MORE TOWARD THE
RIGHT AND NOW THIS WILL BE A
MAJOR TEST FOR THE COURT, NO
DOUBT -- SORRY, ABORTION RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS OPINION -- ABOUT THIS
CASE BEING HEARD AT THE SUPREME
COURT NEXT TERM.
THIS IS DEFINITELY A MAJOR CASE
THAT WE'VE BEEN WAITING TO SEE
IF THE SUPREME COURT WILL TAKE
UP, AND NOW THIS MORNING THE
SUPREME COURT SAYING, YES, IN
FACT, THEY WILL HEAR IT COME
NEXT TERM, GUYS.
>> OKAY.
SO, ELIE, MISSISSIPPI HERE IN
THEIR FILINGS IS SAYING THAT ROE
v. WADE'S LINE IN TERMS OF
VIABILITY OF A FETUS IS
ARBITRARY, BUT THERE IS SOME
HISTORY HERE WITH THIS SAME
CHIEF JUSTICE, CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS SIDED WITH THE LIBERALS
WHEN IT CAME LAST TERM TO THE
LOUISIANA LAW, WHICH HE SAID
ECHOED THE TEXAS LAW THAT WAS
STRUCK DOWN ABOUT FOUR YEARS
AGO.
THE QUESTION IS IS IT DIFFERENT
NOW, THE MAKEUP OF THE COURT IS
DIFFERENT.
>> IT IS POPPY, THAT IS THE
NUMBER ONE FACTOR.
LIKE YOU SAID, ABOUT A YEAR AGO
WE GOT OUR LAST MAJOR RULING OUT
OF THE SUPREME COURT ON ABORTION
WHERE THEY STRUCK DOWN A VERY
RESTRICTIVE LOUISIANA LAW.
IF THAT LAW HAD STOOD, IT WOULD
HAVE ESSENTIALLY MEANT THAT THE
ENTIRE STATE OF LOUISIANA HAD
ONE DOCTOR WHO WAS LEGALLY
LICENSED TO PERFORM ABORTIONS.
THE SUPREME COURT CAME DOWN WITH
A SOMEWHAT SURPRISING 5-4 RULING
WHERE CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
JOINED THE THEN FOUR LIBERAL
JUSTICES TO MAKE A MAJORITY.
SINCE THEN THE BIGGEST CHANGE IS
THAT JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
HAS PASSED AND BEEN REPLACED BY
AMY CONEY BARRETT.
IF YOU ASSUME THAT JUST INN
GINSBURG'S VOTE WILL FLIP OVER
TO AMY CONEY BARRETT YOU COULD
HAVE A DIFFERENT RESULT.
IT'S A 6-3 COURT, CONSERVATIVES
HAVE SIX, LIBERALS ARE THREE.
YOU WOULD NEED TO SEE CHIEF
JUSTICE ROBERTS PLUS ONE OTHER
CONSERVATIVE JOIN THE LIBERALS
TO GIVE A RULING IN FAVOR OF THE
LIBERAL POSITION.
>> THE BACKGROUND HERE IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE ROE v. WADE
HAS BEEN A TARGET OF
CONSERVATIVES FOR YEARS.
BY THE WAY, AS THEY CHOOSE
JUSTICES FOR THE COURT AND OTHER
HIGH COURTS, THEY'RE LOOKING AT
WHAT -- HOW THEY MIGHT DECIDE
CASES LIKE THIS.
I JUST WONDER THEY'VE ALL BEEN
ASKED IN THEIR CONFIRMATION
THESE QUESTIONS, THEY ALL HAVE
AN ANSWER FOR IT, TEND TO SORT
OF SAY, WELL, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
GOING TO BREAK WITH PRECEDENT,
BLAH BLAH.
DOES THAT REALLY MEAN ANYTHING
OR ARE WE GOING TO SEE WITH THIS
COURT WHAT CONSERVATIVES HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH FOR
DECADES NOW, IF NOT OVERTURNING
ROE v. WADE CERTAINLY
RESTRICTING ABORTION MORE?
>> I PUT ALMOST NO STOCK IN THE
STOCK ANSWER OF I'M JUST GOING
TO FOLLOW PRECEDENT BECAUSE,
GUESS WHAT, THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES DO, THEY DECIDE WHAT
THEY THINK THE PRECEDENT IS AND
WHAT THE PRECEDENT MEANS.
THIS IS A MAJOR ISSUE.
IT'S SORT OF REMAINED QUIET,
RETIFL QUIET IF YOU LOOK
NATIONWIDE IN THE SUPREME COURT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
CLEARLY THE POSITION OF THE NEW
JUSTICES ON ABORTION HAS BEEN A
MAJOR POLITICAL AND LEGAL
ANIMATING FACTOR.
LET'S REMEMBER THE THREE NEWEST
JUSTICES ALL APPOINTED BY DONALD
TRUMP DURING HIS TERM